hey you guys welcome back to my flickers
of fear show i'm so happy to be finally
getting around to doing this movie
because this has got to be
one of my favorite horror films of the
2010s
and i feel like i don't really see that
many people talking about it which is
kind of a shame i first saw this i think
back in summer of 2016
maybe it was a little bit later than
that and i was just like blown away by
just this this is a [ __ ] bonkers
movie uh and just kind of like the whole
atmosphere of it just the whole
everything about it like really just
pulled me in and like intrigued me and
this is one of those movies and this
doesn't happen that often i have to say
this is one of those movies that after i
was done watching it like i immediately
went and wanted to watch like other
videos about it like explaining it and
other kind of things because this movie
has
kind of a weird like surrealist type of
[ __ ] going on in it and i think there is
actually something going on there but it
is very like nightmarish and very like
dream logic so
i don't know i don't know if it's better
to just like watch it
and just kind of just let it wash over
you as though it was a nightmare or if
you're trying or if you should try to
like
interpret it symbolically i mean i think
you can enjoy it really either way but
this is a movie that
really is it's one of those ones that
kind of rewards repeated watching so i
really liked to
um you know i was really happy to watch
this one a second time because like i
said it's been a couple years since i've
seen it and it was one that i saw a
couple years ago and it really really
stuck with me so this movie is called
baskin
and it premiered at the toronto film
festival i believe in uh fall of 2015.
now this is a turkish film
and it's actually the uh feature length
directorial debut of um a guy named khan
evernote hopefully i'm pronouncing that
at least sort of right uh i'm just
saying this obviously i'm not turkish so
i'm sure i'm gonna butcher like a bunch
of names in his so i'm apologizing in
advance so the title baskin at least
according to google translate
the most common translation is raid
but it also means things like incursion
or foray
it means things like that so it has like
a lot of different definitions which i
think is really interesting because
pretty much any of those definitions
could apply to what's going on in this
movie
this movie it's like picture if
it's really weird because it's kind of
like the first half
is this really creepy dream like
surrealist
dread inducing
you know thing where it's just
everything is just like a portent of
doom kind of thing and it's just like it
just builds up and builds up gorgeous
like cinematography like the way it's
shot is really really awesome like the
lighting and everything it's all at
night there's no day shots
and then like right at about the halfway
point like right about 45 50 minutes it
goes full on [ __ ] gore fest
so it's kind of like i said imagine if
david lynch
directed
a zoroastrian version
of hellraiser and then maybe you're kind
of getting there
um can evernote actually said that uh
some of his
hellraiser was a big influence uh you
know clive barker stuff in general uh he
said also the descent uh you know the
the caving movie that brilliant uh
british movie also apocalypse now which
actually wouldn't i don't know if that
would have occurred to me necessarily
but when he said that
um you know in the interview i was kind
of like oh okay i see it i see what
you're doing there but yeah so i can
definitely see now i i will say that
there might be
because i've seen some kind of um
reviews of this where people were just
like they really really liked it but
they're like what the [ __ ] did i just
watch like what did it all mean
and i do feel like i'm not sure if this
is the case and maybe if anyone uh knows
more about turkish culture than i do uh
you can tell me i do feel like maybe
some of the
stuff that doesn't
that doesn't carry over doesn't
translate as well might simply be a case
of people like americans or whoever is
watching this being not that familiar
with turkish folklore or mythology
because i do kind of feel like there's a
lot of that going on and i actually did
see a couple of videos where it was
pointing out a couple of things that
were in the movie that were specifically
referencing uh some turkish
superstitions or folklore or something
like that so there actually is a lot of
that going on
so what ended up happening with this was
that canada vernal
had made a short film i think back in
2013
of the same name and it essentially had
the same story
but i guess he was showing it at like
some horror convention or something and
somebody like and he got kind of talked
into man you should like make that into
like a full-length feature because
that's [ __ ] awesome
so he actually did end up doing this uh
it cost i think it cost 350 000 to make
they shot it in 28 days um he was
talking about i was reading this uh one
interview with him and he said they shot
it over 28 well 28 nights really because
like i said there are no day shots it's
all night time and uh he's like in a lot
of the places that we shot and he's like
we shot in istanbul
and he's like and we didn't have
permits or we weren't really sure how
solid like the permits were and he's
like because of the nature of the stuff
they were filming there's like a lot of
gore there's a lot of naked people a lot
of nudity and weird sexual [ __ ] going on
so he's like um you know we were really
like constantly afraid that we were
gonna get caught you know that somebody
was gonna like come in and raid the
place and like [ __ ] you know shut him
down and everything but thankfully that
did not happen and then this movie came
out i kind of first heard about this
i don't remember where i heard it but
like i said periodically i go through
these lists of like you know best horror
nobody's seen and honestly this one i
don't think it's on there anymore but
when i first watched this one it was on
netflix but it always came up you know i
guess as it does it came up sort of near
the bottom of the search you know what i
mean because it's like it's foreign or
whatever but i had seen like a recom a
couple recommendations for it on like
various horror sites i was like man you
got to see this so i definitely wouldn't
watch it and i was uh really really not
sorry i do not think it's on netflix
anymore at least in the united states i
actually watched it it said it's weird
because i did a search and it said it
was on hulu but i didn't i couldn't i
have hulu and i couldn't find it on
there i actually ended up just watching
it i think i rented it from google play
or microsoft something or whatever
like but you can rent it like various
places and i think you can also buy it
on like a nice blu-ray that have because
i was watching a review of it from
bloodbath and beyond that channel and
they had the blu-ray of it and that
actually also has the short film on it
as well um which they actually liked
better than the full-length one but like
i said i can't i haven't seen the short
film so i don't really know so
this movie like i said it's so
it's batshit insane okay one it one
thing two in the third act like the last
like the second half of it once you know
it starts going in that way
uh some of the gore and stuff like that
is pretty
extreme uh not in the sense of oh
there's blood splattered everywhere i
mean there is but
just some of the stuff that happens
is real
grody like real uncomfortable to watch
so if you're real squeamish
i would not recommend this any shape way
shape or form um it's not the worst
thing i've ever seen but some of the
[ __ ] that happens it is pretty [ __ ] up
um so
if you can't deal with handle gore or
you know close-up kind of because the
special effects in this are unsettlingly
good you know so if that's gonna bother
you i you know maybe watch like the
first half and then turn it off because
after it gets about the 45-50 minute
mark it's gonna start getting real real
gross so uh you might just want to tune
out but i'm just so i'm just warning you
ahead of time it's like a trigger
morning it does get out of really nasty
toward the end so okay so what we have
the very beginning of it and like i said
the first half of this i just [ __ ]
love
and i can't even put my finger on what
it is but i [ __ ] love
this every single thing that happens in
this movie even if it seems on the
surface to be like innocuous
every single thing has like a portent of
doom everything is ominous and it's
really really and even if you're not
entirely sure what the [ __ ] is going on
it's just everything has this kind of
like just dripping with dread and it's
just so awesome like the way it's set up
so the first scene of it is like there's
actually like a little kid
and he's in bed or whatever and he hears
something and he goes out into the
living room and like the tv is on but
it's all static
and then he looks back toward his own
room and like it turned like uh the
light in the room like turns red and
he's like flipping out and like i guess
he hears his mom and somebody like
having sex in their bedroom or something
and he's like pounding on the door but
they won't open it
um so this first part you don't find out
until later on but this first part is
actually like a recurring nightmare uh
that one of our main characters has so
after this opening
uh which is like i said it's really
really great it's super super creepy
just like the way it's set up
and um so after that you're in we're
introduced to our main characters and
these are five cops uh and they're all
friends and their names are remzy who's
kind of like uh they call him boss remzy
so i guess he's kind of like the the
highest ranking or the one in charge uh
arda who is the young rookie uh you know
he's the youngest of them he's just
joined the force apparently and he's
also you find out later a grown-up
version of the kid that we saw in the
original so he's the one that was having
that uh recurring nightmare there's a
dude named yavuz who's kind of uh kind
of like the loudmouth of the group he's
always kind of like coming up with these
crazy ass stories and he's real like
tough guy but he comes across as like
real insensitive or not insensitive
insecure um so when somebody like laughs
at him or he perceives that somebody has
laughed at him he gets like all tough
but he's also kind of a coward um
there's also appo
and uh safety
now all of them are there you know
there's this little restaurant like out
in the middle of nowhere and they're all
sitting there apparently they're having
their shift meal or dinner or whatever
and they're all sitting there like
shooting the [ __ ] they're talking about
gambling then they uh pretty much
they very quickly like go into this
conversation about [ __ ] a chicken and
then
uh 70 of all turkish men lose their
virginity to animals and it's all this
other kind of situation and then yavuz
tells this story about picking up a hot
uh sex worker that looked like a
victoria's secret model like just
walking down the street and then getting
home and finding out that she was
actually a man and then just like having
sex with her anyway because why not they
were already there and so there's this
whole like thing going on they're all
kind of like shooting the [ __ ] and like
i said even this where they're all just
like joking with each other and betting
on soccer matches and stuff
it's like it might seem like their
conversation like i said is innocuous or
just you know just kidding around but
every single thing that's said either
says something about each dude's
personality or
foreshadows something that happens later
on this is why i think this is one of
those movies that i could see myself
like watching again and again just
trying to pick stuff up because it seems
like everything in this
kind of means something or kind of like
relates to something that happens later
on
now while they're all hanging out the
one guy safie
he's kind of been like sitting away from
the others and he seems like he's not
feeling too good like he's like oh man i
have this horrible headache and all this
other kind of [ __ ] and they're asking
him you know if it's gone away he's like
no it's you know he still feels like
crap right and they don't really know
why
and so this whole thing this whole thing
happens where like the waiter comes over
um and he overhears part of yavuz's uh
you know prostitute story and the waiter
laughs at which point javooz gets all
like upset and he's just kind of like
what the [ __ ] are you laughing at are
you saying i'm gay and all this other
kind of stuff um you know and so then
they kind of like start a whole fight
and everything so while they're in the
middle of that safety
actually like gets up and like puts his
hand over his mouth like oh man i'm
gonna like barf and like uh you know
runs into the bathroom
now while he's in the bathroom
and while uh the rest of the guys are
kind of like there's this sort of tussle
going on out in the main restaurant
between them and the waiter and then
like the waiter's dad or the owner of
the restaurant or whatever so safe he's
in the bathroom
and he barfs all over the sink and then
he notices that there's a frog in the
soap dish which he thinks is really
weird and like i said that doesn't sound
creepy but it's creepy like in the movie
um and so he's just kind of like what
the [ __ ] is like a [ __ ] frog and then
like he leans down and he's kind of like
washing his face and it looks like
there might be maybe um a hooded figure
behind him like in the mirror but you
can't really see it clearly and it's
like maybe it's just the thing on the
wall you can't really see it and then he
basically looks in the mirror and
screams
um at which point like all the other
guys come running and be like dude what
the [ __ ] is going on and he basically
says something to them about like oh i
just felt like losing my mind for a
second
now he says he's feeling better all of
them kind of get their [ __ ] together
after the little fight with the waiter
or whatever and they're just kind of
like okay we're gonna go back in the van
now safi
even though he's just thrown up
everywhere and said he was losing his
mind he's like uh i'm gonna drive and
everybody's like uh bro no you're not
going to but he insists he's like you
know you're not i'm fine you know i can
drive i've been driving since i was four
years old he says
so they all get in the cop van
and uh kind of go out and like i said
it's it's kind of out in the middle of
nowhere so it looks like maybe not much
is going on around here and so they're
all just kind of like hanging out you
know they turn a song on the radio and
they're all kind of singing along and
it's kind of this big happy thing then
all of a sudden they get a call over the
radio now
there's apparently this other uh cop
unit and they are calling for backup
in this place called and i know i'm
gonna pronounce this wrong like i it's
looks like it's spelled i n c e a g a c
you know i'm not really sure how you
even pronounce that in english but i was
trying to listen to how they were saying
it in the movie and it almost sounds
like they're saying like in josh or
something like that that i know that's
probably really wrong but that was like
closer than what i would have attempted
but uh yeah so they get a call uh for
that place and they're like okay we need
somebody here for backup because there's
some [ __ ] going on so they're all kind
of like uneasy about this they're like
yeah i've heard of that place it's
around here um and they said they'd
heard a bunch of like nasty stories
about it like when they were kids like
there was almost like weird legends
about it or some [ __ ] but they could
they weren't real specific about what
they were
and um so and then they also say
something about there being a bunch of
shrines there and then they're like well
that doesn't make any sense that there
are all there's shrines there but then
there's like all these nasty stories
about it like which is it
and then it almost comes to a thing like
safee is driving and he's like look i've
driven on this road for 10 years and
he's like then i'm driving and i kind of
don't know where i'm at now and it's
like there should be a right turn like
going to the place where we're supposed
to go but it's not there so it's almost
kind of like they're lost even though
it's an area that they're very very
familiar with and then um safety
sees what appears to be a buck naked man
running across the road like in front of
the van and he's just like what the [ __ ]
was that so it's like he stopped so none
of the other guys see it and they're
just like are you just are you high what
the [ __ ] it's like we told you you
couldn't drive you know because you were
sick or whatever and so they get out of
the van and they can't find anybody and
then like on the side of the van there's
like all these weird like scratches that
almost kind of look like letters or
symbols or something like that but not
really it's kind of like not very clear
and they're like man i'm pretty sure
that wasn't there before and then they
look out like on the side of the road
and there's all these frogs and they're
like what the [ __ ] and then they start
like teasing safety's like oh maybe it
was a bunch of frogs like jump together
into the shape of a man and that's what
you saw and so they're just like well
okay well they'd look around but they're
like obviously there's nobody here so
they get back in the van and get back to
like where they're uh going they're
still teasing safety about like seeing
a man in the road and because nobody
else saw him and then all of a sudden
there very very definitely is a man in
the road and the van hits him like
faison like runs him over
and then the van goes like veering off
the road and goes into like a ditch and
there's like a like a river type of
thing
so all of the cops like you know they
all get out of the van it's not like
super deep like the water
and then they're all just like what the
[ __ ] is everybody okay and it seems like
everybody's okay
but then uh they go and there's these
people like sitting around
sort of like a camp
type of situation and they're all like
really weird and they're all kind of
like looking at these cops like
just suspiciously i'm not really sure
what the look is it's just very very
unsettling
and they're basically like oh it had an
accident hon they're kind of like
laughing at him about it and also they
also have like a big bucket of frogs so
frogs are like a recurring uh you know
theme in this movie so at this point uh
the people at they're like okay well
where's this place that we're supposed
to go and they're like oh it's just
through there and one of them kind of
like you know helps them find where the
place is so when they get to where this
place is it's this big creepy abandoned
building obviously because it has like
ivy and [ __ ] growing all over the front
of it and there's a cop car in the front
that there's nobody in so they're like
well they're assuming that this is the
cop car that got there first and was
calling for backup so this is the place
we're gonna go so they're gonna go in
there and one of the guys comments that
oh i remember hearing about this place
when i was a child back in the ottoman
days this used to be a police station
but nobody's been here for a really long
time and it's abandoned now
now once they go into this house
uh that's where [ __ ] starts getting
real hell razory i mean would say okay
so they go in
and they're obviously looking for the
other guys like the other cops like that
called them you know for backup and all
but they all they find is one dude who's
kind of like over having a blair witch
moment like in one of the rooms he's
basically standing with his face to the
wall like it's concrete this concrete
bunkery type thing and he's just like
repeatedly banging his head against the
concrete
and they cut trying to kind of try to
talk to him but he just is like [ __ ]
crying and making like weird groaning
sounds and he won't really tell them
anything also there's some weird [ __ ]
going on with like these things that are
hanging in there that almost look like
they look like they're made from kind of
hair or meat or something or like they
look you know they look like somebody
made them like it's some kind of like
talisman or some [ __ ] like that so
they're all the that kind of [ __ ] like
hanging around in there and then while
they're kind of looking around and
they've separated
one of them i think it's safety he like
wanders off and suddenly
there's a whole bunch of naked bloody
people
just like
[ __ ] each other and they're torching
there's people in cages and there's
people like cutting up other people it's
just it gets like real [ __ ] crazy
like that you know what i mean so and
then and he gets dragged off and he's
like screaming and everything like that
so then the rest of the movie
is them
in this place
with all of these kind of like weird
animalist it's almost kind of like a
demonic i'm not sure what it is exactly
like i said it's almost kind of like a
demonic cult or something like that and
the head of this demonic cult
is this
person
they call him uh i think he's called the
father or sometimes they call him baba
and he's this kind of little like
shorter dude who has this really really
like
weird looking face
and he has like a keyhole like in the
middle of his forehead
and he's like around his neck he has
like all these like padlocks and [ __ ]
like that now interestingly that actor
uh was not an actor he was actually a
guy that uh ken evernol had found i
think he worked in a like a car parking
lot like he was like a parking attendant
or something and he has some kind of um
he had some kind of skin condition
and so much like you know somebody like
michael berryman or some somebody like
that those in the hills have eyes that
had sort of like a strange uh look
because of some kind of you know birth
thing that happened at their birth or
whatever they're like well let's make
that into a thing like you know so i
guess because the first time i saw this
movie i'm looking at that guy going man
that is like a really weird looking dude
and i was like that makeup looks amazing
or you know if you know it's obviously
not cgi but then i found out later that
it's like that's not makeup that's that
dude's actual face so um so yeah so
he yeah he's very uh you know i know he
can't help looking like that but it's a
little uh it's a little unsettling so
essentially what this might be and like
i said when it gets to this point if
you're squeamish like do not watch this
part because i mean people's
intestines get pulled out like just
right in close up just pulling them out
uh people's eyes get gouged out like
close up um there's a whole thing where
like yavuz
uh after his eyes get gouged out he's
forced to like rape this woman that's um
that's like wearing an animal head and
then she like gives birth to some weird
baby thing that i'm not really even sure
what it's made of it looks like kind of
like a pork roast i don't even know what
it is it's like this [ __ ] crazy ass
thing so it's like all kind of like
nasty [ __ ] ensues uh during this thing i
mean what i got from this
was that
it's basically like
and it's weird too because like in
between like all of this gory [ __ ] every
now and then they have a scene where
they go back to
arda and boss remzy
and they'll be like in the restaurant
where they were at the beginning and
they're having like a conversation
about dreams usually and one of those
scenes actually and i think uh i wrote
about this on my blog a while back like
the first time that i saw it and one of
those scenes actually really reminded me
of the winkie's diner scene from uh
mulholland drive the david lynch movie
because it's kind of like what you find
out during the one of these kind of
weird dream like like interstitials is
that arda who like i said was the kid in
the nightmare at the beginning he was is
telling boss remzy about that nightmare
that he had when he was a kid and
basically what it was he's like i used
to have this little friend back when i
was like 10 or whatever
and
we were coming home one night and his
dad had just died and so we were kind of
talking about death and we made this
agreement that
if one of us died before the other one
we would try to visit the other one like
as a ghost but without scaring them
so he's like so we did so we had that
conversation and then my friend got on
the ferry to go home and he's like and i
went home and then i couldn't get i
couldn't get to sleep and then he's like
then when i did get go to sleep i had a
dream
that all of these people were like
looking at me and they were like glaring
at me and then his little friend like
came out of the crowd and said i'm here
don't be afraid and then he basically
says that the next day he found out that
his little friend had died he'd been
like hit by a car so that was actually
his friend like because he said that red
light coming on that that he knew that
his friend was in the room and he was
gonna see him like a ghost but even
though he had told him he wouldn't be
afraid he was still afraid so he said
that was a recurring nightmare that he
had so basically between that and then
then it gets like really surreal like
blood comes out from under his hands and
then he's like underwater and there's
like a big giant hand like coming at him
like the the imagery in this is really
really awesome and like i said that's
kind of where it gives me a very
surrealist like lynchian kind of vibe
because it really has all this nightmare
this dreamlike kind of imagery and if
you're
you know if you want like a real literal
interpretation of it it's you know it
kind of defies that a little bit but
everything in there kind of makes sense
in a weird sort of way i've also seen
this compared to uh lucio folgi uh
particularly the beyond which it does
have a little bit of that kind of vibe
too just because it's this just weird
surrealist kind of thing with all this
like crazy gore in it so
i mean if
if that's kind of like your jam then
you'll probably be in this like it's
very very clive barkery also
and uh can't even all have said that uh
that cloud barker was a big influence on
this movie in particular but yeah so
what we're led to believe is happening
is that either
because there's a thing where uh baba
tells them that
hell isn't a place you go it's something
you carry around with you like all the
time
so you're kind of led to believe that
all of this stuff that's happening
inside of this house or you know this
place
is
sort of like some kind of judgment or
some kind of like purgatorial test or
something like that because what
actually ends up happening later on is
that pretty much all of the dudes get
killed except for arda because we're
meant to think that perhaps because
we've seen arda's dreams like as a kid
and everything like that that we're kind
of seeing everything from arda's
perspective that this is kind of like
his story or his journey or whatever his
dream because like i said this movie
i feel like it's kind of like a dream
within a dream within a dream it's one
of those kind of situations
so
so even when he's going back and forth
like talking to boss remzy about the
dream and stuff i think that's a dream
too and i think them going to the house
is a not necessarily a dream but they've
just been like pulled off
this road there's a lot of references to
like roads and journeys and things like
that so this is almost kind of like
it's like a descent into hell sort of
situation and it could be also like some
kind of judgment situation and that
maybe arda was the only one that was
quote unquote pure enough to have gone
through here unscathed because he's the
only one that doesn't get killed and
what ends up happening interestingly is
that boss rendy who they established
later on is actually um arda's caretaker
because i guess arda's parents died like
a year after his little friend died like
in the situation he described earlier
and um boss remzy who i think was his
uncle or just like a family friend or
something like took over his care so
he's actually been raising arda and so
uh so he's kind of like his father
figure
so
even before they go into the abandoned
house
boss ramsey says something which seems
meaningless at the time but he says i
have the key to everything that's going
on here but what ends up happening is
that at the end when baba is killing all
the other cops like in various
horrifying ways he actually like takes
and like saws boss remzy's throat open
and then it pops back to like a
restaurant the restaurant again and arta
and boss remzy are the only people there
boss remzy basically says i you know
you're seeing them too so
baba from what i can understand like i
said i don't know a lot about like kind
of this turkey turkish folklore and
stuff like that this is based on but i
think baba is supposed to be tara baba
who is sort of like a dream demon and
his thing is like he takes children so
so we're led to believe that this is all
kind of happening in a dream state and
it's almost like a purgatorial type of
situation where boss remzy has seen them
and it's almost kind of like they came
to claim him but because arda was there
um boss ramsey almost kind of like
sacrificed himself because he actually
drew baba away from away from arda and
was like yeah come take me instead so he
he cuts his throat open and arta finds a
key inside boss ramsay's neck like in
the in the wound and he sticks it in uh
baba's head like in the keyhole tattoo
on his forehead and that kind of like
kills him so arda gets away but then at
the very end there's like this weird
like time loop thing where arda gets
away and he's like all covered in blood
and he's like laughing like maniacally
or whatever and then he runs into the
road like looking for help and a van
comes around the corner and straight up
runs him over and then they show the van
going into the river just like the cop
van d at the beginning
although now the cop van is empty so
we're led to believe that this whole
night it's been some kind of weird time
loop and it's almost kind of like arda
because he is almost kind of like the
savior figure at least that's how i took
it like i think that there was this
whole purgatorial thing like their souls
were
kind of in some kind of purgatory but
because arda was pure
and he was able to not he was not only
able to kill baba but by sacrificing
himself he saved the other souls maybe
that's kind of like the read that i'm
getting off it but like i said i could
be totally off on it if you guys have
seen it and you have any theories about
it but that's what made the most sense
to me because it seemed very much like
like a nightmare purgatory situation and
he was he kind of like freed all the
other
guys like all the other souls because
you know because of him doing this time
loop or breaking the loop maybe they'd
been in this loop for a really long time
or something like that so if you have
not seen this movie this like i said
this is one of my favorite ones that
i've seen it was one that i had on the
list because i'm like okay i gotta do
that one because i remember seeing that
back in 2016 and i'm like man that was
so great and it just seemed like there's
so much going on in there like i said
the imagery the the way it's shot is
just really
man and like i said i can't put my
finger on it but like just the use of
color and lighting
and it's all it's just so so creepy it
just has even when nothing
seems to be happening that's all this
like i said you know like a frog in a
soap dish it's like it doesn't sound
like
all that creepy but like in the movie
it's super super creepy and it's like i
don't think this movie has a single jump
scare in it really other than maybe like
the guy you know being in front of the
van or whatever um it's just this really
great atmosphere of dread and it's just
so oppressive
and even if you don't know exactly
what's going on you know that there's
something going on and that it's like
nightmare logic and it's just i don't
know it's just one of the best ones that
i saw from the 2010s easily and it's you
know one of the ones that stuck out the
most to me that i remembered the most so
i was really glad that i got to like
revisit it for this and i really really
recommend it not if you're squeamish
like i said because it's very very gory
um and it's there's a lot of weird
[ __ ] up sex [ __ ] in it
and uh you know so
yeah so so there's like intestines eye
gougings they're all kind of like crazy
[ __ ] like that um so if that's gonna
bother you then probably not
also it's very
surreal it's not
narratively
i was gonna say it's narratively
incoherent it's not incoherent but it
jumps back and forth sometimes it's like
you know was oh we're in a van accident
oh and now we're suddenly back in the
restaurant again but it's all like
really creepy and weird so like i said
just approach it as though this is a
nightmare inside a nightmare inside a
nightmare or like i said it's kind of
like a purgatory
type of story like i said it's almost
kind of like
it did kind of it it didn't occur to me
at first but when i saw somebody else
like somebody else reviewed it and they
kind of compared it to lucio folgi like
particularly the beyond i was like yeah
i can see it's not exactly like that but
i can see
where that comparison comes from uh this
one was a lot darker grittier there was
something more going on in this one like
i said it almost had like a lynchian
vibe in some of the kind of scenes
but this is just i i loved this movie so
much i know
i don't know i saw like a lot of other
reviews and a lot of other horror uh
reviewers really seemed to dig it but a
couple other people just couldn't they
weren't down with the narrative thing
they're just like what the [ __ ] was
going on like i didn't get it or you
know i didn't know what it all meant
although to me like watching it a second
time it seemed much clearer that this
was some kind of that this was all
arda's dream and it was some kind of
symbolic journey that he was going on
that would end with him
sacrificing himself to save the souls of
others that was what i got out of it i'm
not entirely sure if that's what the
intention was ken evernote has said that
even though it's kind of based in
mythological tropes and stuff he
basically said he based it on
a nightmare that he had had so that it
didn't necessarily have to make sense
but it's one of those ones that i think
you can project your own meaning onto it
in a way although it seemed a lot more
i'm not going to say straightforward
because it's not but it seemed a lot
less
weird to me the second time i watched it
because i picked up because i had seen
it before i picked up on a lot of like
things in the dialogue and like
symbolism and stuff and i was like oh
okay yeah okay i see what you're what
you're talking about there because i had
totally like missed stuff that boss
ramsay said earlier in the movie about
the key and all this other kind of stuff
i totally missed that
so it was nice to like watch it again
and like pick up on all the stuff i
missed but this is definitely one that
needs a few repeat viewings but as i
said if you have not seen it and you
really want to see some weird creepy
crazy bonkers
movie uh this one's a really really good
one i really dug it and like i said i
don't think it's on netflix anymore
unfortunately but there are a bunch of
other streaming services where you can
find it um i was able to find it pretty
easily so definitely check it out if you
like weird ass horror movies and super
gory horror movies because this is a
pretty intense one and uh let me know
what you thought about it in the
comments and we'll have a discussion
about it and that'll do it for this
flickers of fear and i'll see you guys
on the next one
bye